welcome to this video playing machina
mask lures what gun is this kind of
dinosaurs and magnanimous coulis not
quite sure what musculus or musculus I
don't know I was funny of those names
okay the good old Slav defense went for
them queen bee three line let's see what
time he is coming up with the early six
that's not not very common normally
black tries to capture here and play for
a quickie five so 97's more more usual
um ok just to d3 maybe 23 the German
keeper if all protected you have the
combination of Bishop to m2 G for enter
the queenside expansion is sometimes a
bit tricky because the light squares us
a week but not sure if it is really a
problem in this in this particular
situation
maybe maybe came on I need to go to a
form that's easy but what now
hmm maybe get more pieces into play the
thing in my favor is that I'm simply
better developed and also i'm still
banking on the fact that he's playing
very quickly in a very difficult
position I really would sometime take
some time yes like you have nothing
developed hmm it can very easily happen
that you let you get wiped out quickly
mk4 96 for instance can be a nuisance
yeah okay be three on yeah I guess be
three yes a hard time to the to develop
the bishop okay yeah I one down Bishop
to e3 our e I don't really think a 5s is
any good what's so interesting now
hmm
but that's not not really clear how to
how to get anywhere
we will take on a four of course
yeah I don't know I need to play move
into play move him yeah like a flag
cannot easily develop it should be 796
as a problem Bishop d6 I can play all
kinds of moves are 96 95 96 on dumb yeah
it's not clear to me what he thought he
is doing now takes be a Bishop c5 the
snide be 3 which is not really play
Elias and yeah well now 96 I can follow
up with Roxy one this is the others I
don't know why why is this even playable
a 5 or loop see one not only will see
one shop here probably now Bishop c5 on
anything better i also have the capture
the capture not not clear ok Knight a5
this also attractive going to c6 castles
this knight c6 take c7 Bishop c5 winning
the exchange well
and now is catching up on the clock
realizing how problematic the whole
thing actually is maybe there's
something like winter f form
trying to get some activity yeah this is
maybe the relatively best move to do the
snow f3 f3 there is some castles now I
guess 96 this must be must be right I
don't want to exchange Queens really
maybe this time was right I don't know
it's tough to play rook c8 Queen 86 and
I'm threatening to take on a 70 and
bishops eff check or is having taken
before it's it's just it's just it's a
strong attack I think
and take here take g74 an edge but this
enough don't know and take it first King
takes Bishop c5 is easy so I needs to
take with the night maybe there is
something else Queen c7 for example
maybe an a not so easy to make a move
now rook d8 there is Bishop f6 I think
to totally killing I think it wins a
piece I think at least you can Castle
give up a seven hour wait on group the
eighth i can actually take that's easier
Bishop be six double check King evade a
king a drug to eight mate it's very cute
actually so how to how to do this Bishop
c5 threatening 13 in 27 checkmate look
sir quite good black resides you know I
don't know it was it was very tricky i
spent ages here at the beginning of the
game because i really wanted to make
them make good moves but it's not easy
to play I know I don't really know after
this at the end I couldn't I couldn't
find a totally convincing move and just
played Bishop b2 the computer shows
Quincy far as winning there must really
this whole position looks totally
difficult for black but I didn't see it
what's the point not see 426 is easy if
it takes here I have
a 3 a 3 wow that's exceptionally strong
of course yeah look at this night
mistake no fee if he does something like
that there is this pool and before long
a 3 is super strong sorry okay Quincy 7
has given us the best reply and then
Bishop b2 night fu for Queen B for
weather with the winning advantage for
wide yeah okay still humans playing here
okay Bishop b2 probably not bad but not
not as as pointed yeah Bishop c5 I think
it says probably should probably a loose
somehow a5 given by the engine it's even
better yeah oh this is strong i get to
see 6m so what I played was that wasn't
bad but can be improved upon very strong
ok this is this is probably not so
convincing but it's still very strong
yeah and here yeah I cannot play a slow
move Knight 96 is right something like
this he castles and it's not clear that
I'm winning I still have night c 6 with
a good game but I didn't want him to
Castle so let's do this and this and it
still keeps a significant edge
came that's that's reassuring and Queen
c7 is also the best move that's good
yeah here's funny arrow create it took
me a while but check check double check
check me and made very nice and TT
played this which after Bishop c5 is is
meeting probably this is the only way to
prolong the whole thing check and and
why does a piece up and should win but
this is still slightly tricky to
coordinate and then blitz the sir he
could have tried with still some
practical chances to to hold it or be
objectively of course why this is
totally winning yeah okay I think he
what he did he played I'm sorry if I'm
repeating myself he played all this very
very committal moves instantly and here
this is totally critical this position
who black no okay I don't know thanks
for watching